also I just learned my camera Jake's
camera to shot to shot as it shoots to
go free so you're sick yeah I guess we
should explain like we decide to come to
the studio in film tour free which is
like what we do yeah that's our drop
that's it and we pick today because it's
like the only day that we have for like
the next month pretty much and then I
got ill yeah and my eyes are running my
nose is running
my ears are running they're not actually
running but they're dying like they
think it's only gonna get worse you're
gonna be mony and insufferable to listen
to well I'm gonna what I'm gonna try and
do is I'm going to do the kind of force
talking thing that I used to do as a
teenager when I got home drunk and I
didn't want my parents to know I was
drunk and and sort of oh that yeah yeah
they always knew right yeah but this is
me pretending not to be ill so but there
might be some sniffles so editor Lucas
he's going to do an amazing job of
editing all the fat out please Lucas
hash thank you no pressure so so I this
is probably one of them most
clickbait titles i i'm not even
clickbait just polarizing titles well
the answer is yes yes it is bad if we do
is bad yes thank you for joining
bye-bye I like your impression of the
theme that's quite good
okay so that there there is obviously a
background story to why this is a topic
now yeah but first just to make sure
everybody knows we're talking we're
talking about the array method so you
have an array with stuff in it and
reduce is one of these arenas they can
mutate or process whatever is in it we
do specifically you give it in
accumulator start value and the function
yes and then for each element the
accumulator and element we passed in
whatever the function returns becomes
the new accumulator value yeah
and that just keeps going until the
entire array has been processed that can
be used for a couple of things
there's also be abused for a couple of
things and many things and you did a
tweet my did which was actually
triggered by another conversation that
we had yes you decide this is me
subtweeting one of our colleagues and I
think we've talked about this before
confident but be basically both think
most of the time what reduce is or where
we reduce is used it shouldn't actually
be used there's better ways of achieving
the things where people use reduced
there's a couple of very smooth few
cases where it actually makes sense one
of them is like you want to look smart
yes absolutely
but I mean I want to point out that I'm
not shaming people here well actually
there is one person I'm shaming and it's
myself because I I definitely went
through three phases like learning code
first one my code is very simple I
didn't use things like reg X and array
dot reduce because they were scary agree
and then I learned these things and I
learned all of the programming
techniques of like currying recursion
love I fought you know my using yeah my
code should demonstrate how clever I am
to everyone so I will use all of these
things so anyone can look at any one bit
of my code and they'll go
that guy is smart and he knows lots of
things and then I forgot the other
person doesn't understand your code you
are smarter than that person exactly
yeah yeah yeah and they should just get
cleverer which is really which was like
a lot of the replies that I got to this
thread but I'm now like you know I've
been doing javascript for 20 years and
then kind of I got into this a third
phase which is just like 20 yeah and old
I'm quite old I look particularly all
today illness but I feel like I'm now in
the third phase of my coding experience
which is like I want my code to look
like the code in a beginners book like I
want it to be that straightforward yeah
I definitely over the years I've learned
to appreciate code that you can just
read and you're like I understand what
is happening that is so invaluable when
you have that in a project and you
actually know where to go and fix it and
and so that's basically what I want to
talk about so what I did
ah it's look at some examples and I kind
wanna throw an hypothesis out here where
I think when you see reduce it will fall
into one of four categories for right
okay the first category is it's a Sun or
something in this like is some it's some
like some like I like that the second
category is it should really be just
using array methods maybe which is like
entries an object from entries and those
things are some of those things in you
like from entries is particularly we're
going to talk about that yeah okay and
but basically sometimes I see a reduce
that is just a glorified filter on map
and really you should have been using
filter and map yep the third category is
it's a loop in it like yeah just use a
loop and don't do reduce to abuse you
loop like it just using the loop aspect
of reduce and actually don't use the
thing that makes the reduce reduce
degree right now and the and the third
category is for hashtag I'm smarter than
you
yes and those were examples where I
looked at them and I just couldn't
figure out what they were trying to
achieve so my theories a cure these will
fall into category one two three if I
could understand what they were doing
yeah and I didn't put any examples of
category four in here because otherwise
people were just explaining the comments
to me what this fragment will just be
you know and point in that thread there
was a I was asking people for examples
as well and yes there was a lot of times
where I had to just like really stare
and like I say 20 years of experience
I'm not the smartest person by any
stretch but I wasn't really stare at the
story and then and then once I was kind
of like oh oh oh I know this is doing
now I mean I would write it as a loop
and so much cure to me but then you know
the code you write is always clearer to
you but what yeah and so I thought I
would look at some popular projects Oh
clone them and just do a code search for
doctor reduce what spectrum chair as
spectrum chat is a chat it's Michael
should have figured that out myself
written on this in class back with react
Redux
that's all I remember but I thought you
know if Redux is in there that probably
is reduced and there what was my
assumption and so I just use a couple of
pros I knew looks for the code and
picked some examples of good examples
for these categories that I have let's
see yeah so let's start first category
I'll let you take a look and try to
explain it this one is a pretty easy
start I think oh I see okay yeah okay so
you got an array of durations and you're
trying to find out the maximum one turns
out there's a better way to do this yes
it is that yes there it is I'm not sure
if this is just a parent that exists now
because spread of the thing but even
before that you could use apply or call
and it's easier to read you'd like the
entire reduce just it's more mental
overhead to power so I think this would
be a preferable way to write it
so I heard someone actually say that
this hits a limit of argument count
whereas the other one doesn't
now I I've not tested this so I don't
know what it is but even then I think
you could fold it out to a little even
then it or just and at least contain
this slightly overhead e-version and put
in a function called max yes absolutely
which just takes an array yes right and
even then I'd use a loop yeah because
it'd be faster and easy to read this
interesting noise
I actually am Not sure yes you could
probably write it as a loop but it's so
so the good thing about this example is
they used reduce but they contain the
reduced weirdness in a function so it
takes gives an array of values in order
basically accumulate them up for each
one is the accumulation of those I see
as long as you put it the function has a
descriptive name I actually kind of
don't care how you implement it because
it the functions that use this function
are going to be quite easy to read all
right um clip use a loop in here I don't
think it makes a big of a difference so
this is it's starting to get to the
point where the the things I dislike
about I've just noticed there's a extra
line of this code missing anyway yeah
the final thing so my brains all on fire
now is it starting to get to some of the
stuff I don't like about reduce and one
of the it's a problem with a quite a few
functions in JavaScript it's that the
arguments are in the wrong order
yeah right like if you've got a callback
that needs to go last right or it needs
to be it because yeah because the the
simplest code is read sequentially like
a loop is fine because you go down and
then you go back you got like but it
still sort of sequentially whereas here
to even start to understand
you have to go at the end of the end of
the thing and then read back from there
and yeah and also this is this is
creating a lot of erasers well I mean I
know you didn't you're not going to talk
about performance
oh yeah that's actual thing I think that
mentioning I didn't want to talk about
performance because I feel like the
first order that you look when you look
at code should be readability
so the formants should be a second
priority most of the time because and
that's only because we have reached a
point where the communiques at
performance first to the point where
they have every twenty enough investment
it's just there anymore they optimize
things that don't need optimizing at all
and some people have sacrificed
readability in favor of performance for
performance that they don't need right
but this is doing it sacrificing
readability and performance like
potentially yes yeah I must put this in
because I want to show that if you put
it in a function it has a good name you
can get away with more in my opinion I
absolutely agree with that as well
even then actually I would then take the
opportunity to have it contained you can
write your tests you can do the
refactoring in one place a lot of people
don't like mutations yeah in code but if
you're limiting it just to one function
it's okay yeah I would agree next one I
found an interesting but it's one of the
classic examples basically get a gret
you get you have a list of edges which
you know between two points in the graph
are you trying to build the graph which
you can look up for a start edge all the
connection of the star touch has to over
all the images and this is this example
where you you abusing reduce just for
the loop aspect and the tail here is the
thing that is put here comes out here
and it's just returned it's the same
object every time it's just a loop so
really if you have that just use lupine
this is actually I think so much easier
to understand what's happening because
you create a map if you loop over the
edges you add sets for the edges if they
don't exist yet and then you just add
the interval and just to the right of
corresponds to it yeah if you and now I
know that people like but this is not
pure like I said like some people like
the pure aspect mm-hmm but the pure
version is just not as readable I try to
write one and it like yes it is
potentially understandable but I don't
think that is worth for purity sake yeah
especially because JavaScript to me
is still not a functional programming
language you can write functional code
in JavaScript but it's not functional
programming by nature or by design yeah
so like readability is tangible it's
subjective but it's tangible like you
can look at two things and go that's the
one I prefer performance is tangible
right even you miserable it's measurable
you can see that but when people say
like purity it's like well but what do
you get for it great
and I I understand like you can actually
gain a lot of reliability by avoiding
mutations but again if you're isolating
that into one function and the mutations
I think that's drive it it'd be usually
if small self-contained functions are
your building blocks then you can work
with mutability insight as well to find
scopes because mutation is happening
somewhere right those ones are turning
to zeros and vice versa
at some point so yeah okay that's
current this one I found cute and this
is one of these examples where something
that exists now probably is not exist it
is flat size and so I was like okay
let's let's give them the benefit of the
doubt because probably flat didn't exist
at the time they wrote it yeah so what
they should really have been doing is
just ever hood which is probably exists
at the time yes even then write a
function that's called flat because when
I see this code I have to read it and
like you go huh huh oh it's flat which
is a semantics F so I could make so much
make is so much easier to read
so if flat didn't exist just write this
code the previous code and put it in a
function called 5 yes absolutely it just
makes it easier to read yeah and again
even if I was writing that function I
would I would avoid the many array
create here we go then you would use a
loop because once again and I know that
some people have problems with the hole
or you create a variable and then you
mutated in a loop and when I think it's
easy to read it's easier to follow what
it's actually happening and if if you're
yeah trying to be strict about mutations
as long as it's held within one function
like we said I'm fine with it
couple more examples so this one I hope
that I was like holy crap this is
unnecessarily complicated that's what
they're effectively doing is they're
creating an empty array
I wish they are concatenating to and
returning so it is kind of like oh this
would probably be a loop
so we're pending and this I look and
then I realized oh they want to put
commas in between the individual links
except for the first and the last
element
oh hello it's joined its I just know is
it it is joined however however this is
a list of V Dom nodes of JSX
right so a join that basically
intersperses element between already
existing Emmons and returns a new array
doesn't exist out of the box right I see
yes so this is actually a thing where
this one would give you the wrong result
you can't just use join because the join
returns a string but again write a
function that's called JSX joint or
something which just makes it easier to
pass of what is it actually happens what
is trying to do is put the text node
with a comma in yes in between right I
see okay yeah fair enough I wasn't I
think I loop write a function functions
don't cost anything a loop would have
made that so much clearer to me I like
to say I acknowledge its loop would also
work actually as a good at yeah I just
like in this case you get a bunch of
links and you a bunch of issues and you
turn each issue in its own link tag the
map here I find very expressive yes oh
yeah yeah I mean oh but yes you would
have to change it so you're returning
like you could do it as a flat map
exactly that yeah so you because you
it's valid to have an array where it's a
JSX element and then a string which will
be a text node yeah okay flat knife is
the thing which is also pretty new yeah
again
all right okay so we've got the usual
problem of just passing the object round
and around and around yes
so this is basically something we would
say write a loop except in this case
we're building up an object and when
that's happening in modern JavaScript I
would say this is a use case for object
and treat an object from entries yeah
it's amazing what they were doing is
they look at all the events that were
there and creating a new object it has a
function for each of these events so in
this case you could just use turn it
into an entries list map over the values
to change them how you like and then
turn it back to an object yep this is
actually borderline readable to me I
feel like that if this gets a bit more
complicated the loop might be easier to
read yeah
and again they if the idea is you're
wanting to assign it to a constant
rather than you know because if well
actually even you wouldn't it would be a
constant anyway because it's an object
he doesn't even taste it right and again
farm out to another function and now
this is something you already mentioned
to me earlier so I didn't talk about any
more but this so here's someone who put
it in a function and wrote a comment
really good you're allowed to use
reduced with a comment and an
explanation like I wouldn't have written
it this way necessarily
but you put in a function self and
points to the person who wrote this
what they're doing is add together the
top left bottom right properties of each
client rec but keep width and height of
the first one right so interesting so
that's what they're doing here and now
that I've read the comment I can almost
immediately see that that's what's
actually happening personally I would
have written it like this where I would
actually make the code give that
explanation I would turn each property
into a sum however if this is a hot path
in your code iterating over your
rectangles four times or it's writing
and mapping and summing this could
potentially be a performance
consideration at some point yes in which
case you can turn it into a loop a
single loop potentially I guess yeah so
yeah the the reason we started talking
about this and then you told me to shut
up because you were going to be talking
about it in this episode is when you
know I stuck my neck out and said reduce
is bad obviously I went and looked at
all the code that I'm likely to be
releasing in the next moment for this
like to say you have I use reduce
because you know I'm not a you know I'm
a bit of a hypocrite sometimes and like
I use reduce a few times for adding
stuff together yeah the zammis sums the
one exception was kind of similar to
this but I had an array of client
wrecked objects yeah and I was finding
the bounding total bounds of all of
those and I am still in two minds
whether it's a good used to it finds a
minimum of top the minimum of left the
maximum of bottom and the Maximoff right
basically right yes yeah so you could
map in maximum in yeah would be fine
potentially more expressive but you know
I
and that this was put in a function so
I'm yeah less inclined to actually get
annoyed by it
I really just dislike when there's like
goo reduce in the middle of a bigger
function and then I have to stare and
figure out what is the semantic
equivalent of that reduce yes and that's
probably the any tricks you do if you
can isolate those into a single function
because sometimes tricks make the code
really fast or if you are chasing file
size which is probably shouldn't be but
if you are yeah putting that stuff into
another function even if it's only used
once a good minify err will be able to
inline that yeah and so you get the
benefits of documentation and
readability and you still get to use
your trick in it yeah exactly do I have
more I think I have some more so this is
a parent I've seen quite a bit actually
where m this filter boolean or' that's
invocation is basically a way to say
only keep the truth eval use that's
quite that's kind of cool it's a fun
trick spell it out but but is it fun
filter like F maps to F like it's also
not much more expressive if you like
this is actually a bit more expressive
in the sense what it does true you could
say it reads like filter the billions
from also be misunderstood I agree and I
did actually write a piece of code today
which was filter like f arrow arrow F
and yes in this case I was actually
trying to get rid of the empty strings
yeah yeah I actually that's a good I
don't know which one and maybe I should
have done F equals equals empty string
would have probably been the more
expressive way of doing that so what I
do is they get the edges they filter out
the faulty values and then for each
remaining one or they start with zero
and if the node is seen they don't
increment the count and otherwise they
do so their basic counting the things
that are not seen alright see so I feel
like this should be done differently
because what you could just do is like
you map to is seen then map out the boy
on your side of length right of course
so as so this is going to be either yeah
either doesn't exist or yes yeah that's
much more obvious to me and it's nice
that it's what one of the things I like
about the functional programming thing
is is it
like I said before it's simple code is
sequential
yeah and it's a sequence of steps and if
there's a key if it was a series of
function calls you have to read them
inside out yeah which is not sequential
so this yeah I like that element any
weed yeah this is another example I
think I think a combination of things
really where you just they reduce over a
list see if it has a thumbnail and if it
has a thumbnail it gets pushed into a
list so really what they're doing also
you filter it and then you map it or if
you want to use the new pattern that we
just showed you can map first and then
just filled out the value says both of
these would work just fine all right
this is all the examples and I have ok
quite a bit I thought so you all again
this is these are code examples from
these real crux and some more like this
is real code out there and I feel often
you can have more expressive more
readable code code not cold although you
have an expressive yeah you just make me
feel about um and again like anybody
who'd use this reduced shouldn't feel
bad you're allowed to use reduce this
not wagging our fingers are saying like
here's how we've come to the conclusion
most of the time reduce can be replaced
by something that we would deem better
and it is something that like they say I
have made this mistake in code before
and much worse mistakes with lots of
tricks like I often felt like going back
a few years my attitude to coding was
like I was doing all this smart parkour
when I could have just walked down the
street and got there faster you know but
I wanted people to think I was cool and
yeah pretty much
even if you feel like seen by this if
you think oh yeah that is what I'm doing
you're not alone it's one last thing I
want to point out obviously if you have
these nice sequential sort of a map and
the filter and another map and a flat
map or whatever and some people might be
worried about creating all these
intermediate arrays for the individual
steps which javascript will create under
the hood like one map will create take
the original array and create a new
array it doesn't mutate the existing
array so each step will be basing an
entire copy of the array with a function
applied to it if people are worried
about the intermediate values in arrays
being created there is also a way of
doing this with iterators so i I'm gonna
plug a super old project of mine okay
which is called under -
where I basically collected all the
functions that underscore and similar
Ibis provides and have little two to
three line implementations or then you
can just copy paste so rather than
having a library for it to download
install you just copy paste the code
that you need and I have it for a race
but most of them also have a synchronous
iterator and an asynchronous iterator
version so instead of chaining array
methods you could be working on
iterators which basically prevents all
the intermediate arrays being created
yes because it's passing it's like a
stream it's basically streams yeah yes
and I thought you know somebody's
interesting that take a look at it still
exists on my on my github yep and with
that have is is reduce bad yes yes see
you next time I'm gonna keep that ending
yeah go for it editor Lucas is really
cool and really cool and really really
really cool Lucas